[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Thank you
all for being here.
We have a great guest today.
We have AJ Edelman.
AJ is a four-time
Israeli National Champion
in the skeleton event.
And you represented Israel
in the 2018 Winter Olympics.
AJ EDELMAN: I did.
Yes.
SPEAKER: So thank
you for being here.
AJ EDELMAN: Thank
you for having them.
I finally get the interview at
Google that I never got before.
SPEAKER: So let's
start at the beginning.
You grew up in Boston.
AJ EDELMAN: I did.
SPEAKER: You grew
up playing hockey,
starting at three years old.
So you've been on the ice.
You've been involved
in athletics.
What was childhood like,
being an athlete in the sport?
AJ EDELMAN: Well, I
started at age three.
I started really young,
because my parents,
they believed in giving
my two brothers and myself
the opportunity to have an
active lifestyle if we chose.
So getting on the ice in Boston
was very, very accessible.
I got on the ice at age
three, and I thought to myself
at the time that--
this is probably the
first time I ever
thought in an
engineering kind of way--
but that the expected value
of playing time for a goalie
was a full game.
So that was one right there.
But the expected
value for somebody
who is a defenseman
or center was probably
like a quarter of a game.
So it was a far better value
proposition to become a goalie.
So I decided to become a
goalie, and played in net
for the next 20-plus years.
And sports shaped a good deal
of how I viewed the world
and taught me a lot
of good lessons.
SPEAKER: So growing
up, you played at MIT
when you went to college?
AJ EDELMAN: I did.
SPEAKER: Did you
kind of always know
that you want to stay in
sports and be an athlete
or was this just a fun thing
growing up and a hobby?
AJ EDELMAN: Originally
it started out--
it kind of ebbed and flowed.
So it started as a
serious endeavor.
And around eighth grade,
I had the opportunity
to kind of take it
to the next level.
I had some scholarship
opportunities for prep schools.
That's the route
that you want to go
to take to get to a
D1 level of playing.
And I thought to myself,
well, that's just not what
people from my back--
I'm a religious Jew.
That's really not what
people from my background
generally do.
I probably should just stick
to more academic pursuits
and not pursue that.
And so it kind of
ebbed away, where
it became far less serious.
And then later on, during a year
off in Israel when I was 19,
I decided to rededicate
myself to athletics.
SPEAKER: And so you took some
time off from the athletics,
and you graduate, and you
move out to San Francisco,
and you start working at Oracle.
You have a promising
tech career.
How did you decide
that being an Olympian
was going to be your goal?
AJ EDELMAN: So it's
an interesting story,
but I decided actually in 2013,
when I was in my senior year
at MIT, that I wanted
to be an Olympian.
But how I there was
more process of wanting
to accomplish something great.
It's a mindset that I've
had since childhood.
When I was at age 10, I
moved to a new school,
and I was the odd kid out.
I experienced a lot of bullying
when I was at that school.
And it really left
a lot of scarring.
But when I was there,
one of the ways
that I coped with
the difficulties
was that I thought that, in 20
years, 30 years, none of this
would matter.
None of that time
period would matter.
What would matter is what
I accomplished out of life.
And so I thought
every day, when I'd
experienced all this trouble,
that in 35 years, 30 years, 20
years, I'm going to stand
on top of a mountain.
I didn't know yet
that it was actually
going to be a
mountain, but that I
was going to stand
on top of a mountain,
having accomplished some
pretty good things, having
left my mark on the world.
So over the course of
the 17 years since then,
when I've faced
certain challenges,
that essence of "be the best,"
"accomplish something great"
has come out.
So it happened three
distinct times in my life.
The first was in my
teenage years, when
I was extremely
academically unmotivated,
and I decided to make a shift
at trying to get into MIT.
Because I wrote,
right now you're
unmotivated, make a goal.
I tried to get into MIT.
That was the level
of excellence that I
thought, of going to
an engineering school,
that I wanted to go to.
So I got into MIT.
The second was when I was
in a gap year in Israel 19,
I let myself go from
a physical standpoint.
I'd reached about
200-plus pounds.
I think I tipped the scale
one day at 203 pounds.
And I looked down, I
couldn't see my toes one day,
and I thought, well,
where did that kid
go who said he was going
to be the best of the best?
Like, is this the best version
of you that you can be?
Is this what you really want?
And so at that point, I wasn't
thinking about hockey anymore.
I wasn't thinking about sports.
But I said the way
to deal with what
you're dealing with right now
is become an athlete again.
But don't just
become an athlete.
Be a great athlete.
And so I took a deep
dive on everything
that I could learn about
health and fitness,
lost 35 pounds in three
months, and decided
to try to make the
MIT hockey team.
Made the MIT hockey team, and
then for the next few years,
played at MIT.
But as I came to the end
of my hockey career at MIT,
I was faced with, well,
what do I do next?
And if I'm going to
continue in sport,
it has to be
something that, if I'm
going to sacrifice next
few years of my life,
it has to have an actual impact.
It can't just be great for you.
It has to be great
for the world, right?
It has to have some
kind of impact,
that people will look back
and say, that happened.
And so, one night, I'm sitting--
I don't know if any
of you guys are aware,
but there's a dorm at
MIT called Burton Conner.
I was sitting in the Burton
Conner suite lounge of my dorm,
and the news came on,
the 11 o'clock news.
On that news segment was the
US team trials for Sochi.
And so I saw the
bobsled team going
and I thought, well,
that looks amazing.
Bobsled looks intense.
Like, I'm in the gym all day.
I could push heavy things.
I'm pretty good with my hands
and hand-eye coordination.
I'll do that.
And being an
Olympian would allow
me to speak with some
authority on sports.
And one of my passions is
getting more young Jewish kids
involved in sports, that
have those resources
available to them that may
not be available to them now,
but they can know
that they can be--
sports is a good
outlet for them.
So I thought, all right.
So I'm going to
become an Olympian,
and I'm going to become a
very proud Israeli Olympian.
SPEAKER: So was it
the gap year that you
decided you wanted to
become an Israeli citizen?
And what was that
process like for you?
AJ EDELMAN: In the year
2006, I went to Israel
on a summer tour.
But that summer,
we were supposed
to travel with this group,
north and south across Israel
visiting all these sites.
But the second Lebanon
War abruptly broke out,
and we had to shelter
in place, so to speak,
in Jerusalem for a long while.
There was rockets coming
over the border every day.
I think it really
was the connections
I made during that time, and
just seeing the Israeli society
as they came under attack, that
I formed an immense connection,
like a very intense
connection, deep connection,
to the land of Israel.
And I thought, one day, I'm
going to be an Israeli citizen.
I want to be part
of this society.
And that was when I decided in
2006 that, one day, eventually,
I'd be Israeli.
SPEAKER: And how did
you-- when did you
become an Israeli citizen?
AJ EDELMAN: I officially
became Israeli in 2016.
SPEAKER: 2016.
AJ EDELMAN: Yes.
SPEAKER: OK.
I want to talk a
little about skeleton,
but I don't know if everyone
here who's going to see this
knows what that is.
AJ EDELMAN: Sure.
SPEAKER: So can you
explain the sport
and what it's like to
experience that thrill?
AJ EDELMAN: Sure.
So many people have seen
the movie "Cool Runnings."
Skeleton athletes, we kind
of have a bit of a complex,
because everybody knows
bobsled, and everybody
knows "Cool Runnings."
So we usually start out
our conversation with,
oh, do you guys know
"Cool Runnings?"
And everybody will
nod their head yes.
And they say, well,
do you know there's
another sport called skeleton?
They say no.
So bobsled is where the vehicle
being driven down the track
is the bullet.
They said, let's
take a vehicle, let's
drive it as quick as possible
down a mile long track,
reach speeds of
90 miles an hour,
and somebody steers
with their hands.
Skeleton was, they said, let's
make the human the bullet.
We'll put him on his stomach,
and he'll steer with his head.
And so that's what skeleton is.
You start from a dead sprint.
You have a 70-pound sled.
You put it on the ice.
You sprint about 30
meters down a hill.
You dive forward onto it.
And then you navigate
over a mile long track
under 5G forces,
towards the end.
And whoever reaches the bottom
in the quickest time in one
piece is the victor.
SPEAKER: So I think that's
a very kind of crazy
and interesting
piece to that, is
that you grew up playing goalie,
so you weren't sprinting.
You never really
participated in a sport.
How did you decide
that this was going
to be the one that you were
going to be an Olympian in?
AJ EDELMAN: So as I
mentioned, bobsled
was really the passion
sport of mine that I saw.
And I saw bobsled.
I said, I want to do bobsled.
So I messaged, I googled, is
there an Israeli bobsled team?
It turned out that
there had been,
but they had kind of
hung up their spikes,
so to speak, after trying to
qualify for the 2006 games.
But I found their website.
I messaged them.
I said, hey, I'm this kid.
I'm in Boston.
I'm about to graduate from MIT.
I really want to do
bobsled for Israel.
I really want to start
an Israeli bobsled team.
And so they messaged back,
and they said, listen,
nobody wants to do
this sport from Israel,
and you have to get multiple
people to do it with you.
You can't just do it solo.
So your likely bet,
the best bet for you,
is to do a solo sport
called skeleton.
Go check it out.
So I YouTubed skeleton.
I saw it.
It looked pretty intense,
and I went to try it
in Lake Placid, New York.
And when I tried it in
Lake Placid, New York,
there's a bobsled track that
was used in the Olympics
back in the '80s.
And you get to try it, but they
pad you up like a Michelin man,
so you don't feel any
pain at that point.
If you hit a wall, it just
feels like, easy breezy,
like skydiving.
It's perfect.
You only feel the pain
later, but at that moment,
I was just feeling like I was on
a roller coaster with no belts.
So I was like,
oh, this is great.
I additionally tried speed
skating, and speed skating,
I took to quite well.
But for reasons that were--
skeleton presented
a bigger challenge,
and so I decided
to pursue skeleton.
SPEAKER: So I want to go
into a little bit about how
you trained for this.
There's only so many
tracks in the world.
There's definitely
none in Israel.
I don't believe there's one
in the middle of a desert.
So how did you learn
to do this sport
and become good enough to
qualify at an Olympic level?
AJ EDELMAN: Sure.
There's a lot of moving parts
to training for an Olympics.
specifically for skeleton.
Skeleton is broken down into
the sprinting component,
and then the driving component.
The driving component
is physical skill
with your brain and
hand-eye coordination
and knowing how to manipulate
yourself under 5G forces.
So for reference, 5G forces--
I was about 180 pounds
when I competed on average.
5G forces would feel like
somebody put a 900 pound
human being on my back abruptly
when going through a turn.
So under those heavy
loads, you have
to manipulate your shoulders and
your knees to torque the sled.
And it's an incredibly
difficult thing to do,
because if you do it incorrectly
by a few fractions of a second,
you can drive yourself to the
roof or down to the floor,
and you can severely--
you can concuss yourself.
So I decided that the number one
way to become good at anything
is by dedicating the
entirety of your time to it
and achieving 10,000 hours.
I was told originally that I
was really bad at the sport.
Like, really atrocious.
I lacked all the skills
necessary for doing it.
The scouting report
originally was
that I lacked the tools
necessary to become
a competitive skeleton
athlete, that I might
be on a small scale
developmentally competitive
on a lower circuit,
but would never
achieve a measure of
success in the sport itself.
So that, to me, was a challenge.
And the reason that they said
that was because, unknown to me
at the time, when I entered a
corner in those early training
runs in Lake Placid, , I
would always kink my body
to the right.
And I didn't know why.
But they said, you
should probably
see a chiropractor for that.
It's like, well, why?
It wasn't until
years later that I
realized that I found out
after we did a body scan
that I had some scoliosis.
The second aspect of it
was that I couldn't sprint.
I was an atrocious
sprinter, and the sprinting
is more than one
third of your run,
essentially, because of
the compounded velocity.
And so to overcome my
deficit in the sprint,
I thought I was just
going to become the best
driver that I could be.
So 10,000 hours over four years
is about eight hours a day
for seven days a
week for 365 days
a year for four straight years.
I had a job at the
time at Oracle.
I had a real life.
So what I did was I left a video
loop of YouTube on every day.
I watched at least six to
eight hours of World Cup
footage of skeleton, and
then I would mentally
visualize myself going down
the tracks to create what
are called neural pathways.
The neural pathways
we have in our brain,
they're highways of
information, and the more
you think about
something, the quicker it
is to make that connection.
And so I would watch six to
eight hours of these videos.
I'd put myself on
a skeleton set.
I'd lie down, and
I'd imagine myself
going through the track,
six to eight hours a day,
every day, for 365 days
a year, over four years.
I reached 10,000 hours.
That was how I
trained originally
when I wasn't on the ice.
When I was on the ice, I
took three to four times
the recommended run volume
for a skeleton athlete.
So skeleton athlete is supposed
to take two to three runs a day
for head health reasons.
I took about eight runs
a day, seven runs a day.
It takes a tremendous
physical toll.
But it also means
that you can speed up
that process of making
those connections.
And I took to the sport because
of that, not very quickly,
but I reached a level that
I was looking to reach
in a short amount of time.
SPEAKER: You mentioned that
you used virtual reality too
as part of that.
How did that play
into your training?
AJ EDELMAN: Those mental runs
that I was doing, at one point,
I thought there was a
way to up that game.
So I got myself a gear
headset for my phone,
and I loaded up a
point of view video,
and I would lie down on
my sled and put the gear
headset over my head, and just
for an hour at a time, just
watch a running loop of myself
going down the skeleton track,
and then practicing the
movements to familiarize myself
with what I would do if I was
in the track at various points
in time.
SPEAKER: So you
knew 10,000 hours
was going to take four years.
And you started four years
before the 2018 Olympics.
AJ EDELMAN: Yes.
SPEAKER: And when did you
realize that you actually
had a shot at making
this Olympics and not
the next Olympics?
AJ EDELMAN: To put it
all into context, really,
the goal was to make
the 2022 Olympic Games.
So when I was told that
I lacked the components
necessary to become a
competitive skeleton athlete,
I thought, well, it
was my 23rd birthday.
It was March 14 of 2014.
I sat down in the cafeteria
at the Lake Placid Olympic
Training Center, and I
googled how many days
until the 2022 Olympic Games.
It turned out that
there were 2,884 days.
So I sat down at the
table and I said,
wrote on a piece of paper,
2,884, I circled it.
And I said that for 2,884
days, I wouldn't stop training,
and if I didn't make the
Olympic Games in 2022,
only then could I
stop that journey.
In 2016, it was an incredibly
difficult year for me,
but it was the first
time that I participated
in a world championships.
And after the world
championships,
most people hang up their
spikes for the season.
They're done.
It occurs in
mid-February, and they
think that it's their
last competition.
They go home.
But I thought like--
I have a mindset that if you're
not training on Christmas,
your opponents are.
So I had a month to
gain valuable experience
on my opponents that
they weren't taking.
So I thought, well, where's
the latest track open?
And it turned out
that it would be
Sigulda, Latvia, was open
until March 16 of that year.
So I had a month
to go to Sigulda.
I had no experience in Sigulda.
And Sigulda, it
turns out, that it
is the probably most physically
punishing and dangerous track
on tour.
So I headed to
Sigulda, and every day,
for three, four, or five
times a day, I'd run down,
you know, I'd take my rounds
down the Sigulda track,
I broke an ankle while
I was in Sigulda.
It was an incredibly
painful time.
It took a tremendous
mental toll.
On March 14, it was
two years after I'd
made the 2,884 day commitment.
But that day, I spent it
alone at the bobsled track.
Nobody was there, but I was
working out late at night.
And I just decided-- like,
I'd reached burnout point.
So I decided like, I'm
just going to quit.
I'm finished.
I'm done.
So I was messaging Oracle at
the time, who had given me
a leave of absence.
So I was messaging them that I
was going to come back a little
early.
But before I did that,
I watched the commercial
that Procter and
Gamble puts out.
It's an amazing commercial.
You guys should go YouTube
it when this is done.
It's called "Thank You, Moms."
And it's a really powerful
commercial that always moved me
to tears, because it goes
through these kids from when
they're extremely young, and
they're falling on their butts,
and it's a figure skater,
and she falls in competition.
It just goes
through their years.
Their mom's always
down on the sidelines.
And then eventually it cuts
out, and the next scene
is the Olympians going through.
And then they point to
their mom in the crowd,
you know, they're crying, and
I'm crying, everybody's crying.
So that to me was like,
am I really going to quit?
I should be that dude.
So at that point,
I messaged Oracle
that I was going to leave
them and pursue skeleton
as a full-time endeavor.
And that was when I made
the commitment that it
wasn't just going to be 2022.
It was going to be 2018.
SPEAKER: So when
did you qualify,
and when did you
know you were going
to be in the 2018 Olympics?
AJ EDELMAN: The
qualification came down
to the last two races.
It was really-- the
season was in severe doubt
from the outset.
From the beginning,
the athlete is
supposed to qualify the
country, not himself.
And so it works on
a ranking system.
If a skeleton athlete achieves a
rank that is of certain ranking
relative to his peers,
then the country
gets an invitation to
go to the Olympic Games,
and they can send who they want.
And so from the
beginning of the season,
we had myself and another
potentially competitive
skeleton athlete, and
there were two circuits
that we can compete on.
One of the circuits
traditionally
provided a better points
opportunity, a better
ranking opportunity, for
which to get that invitation.
The thing is is that everybody
took a look at the last cycle
and said, OK, so that
one's far better.
So everybody is like--
so we're all going
to go to that one.
So all the competitive athletes
went to that mid-level circuit
which I was training on.
Nobody showed up to
the lower level races.
So there was an
immediate option.
What do we do do?
Do both' Israeli athletes
go to the lower level races,
or do we go one to each
race to cover our bases,
and hold the other athletes at
the other race back from points
while the other one
accrued his points?
And so the team
leadership aspect
demanded that we split the time,
and that, I, as Israel's number
one, go to the more
difficult competitions.
So for the entirety
of the season,
I was actually down in
points, not in a position
to qualify for the games
until the final two races.
So the cutoff for qualifying
for the Olympics was January 14.
The Olympics started
on February 9.
The cutoff was January 14.
Everybody would know if they had
kind of made it by January 16.
January 10 and 11 where the
final two races in Lake Placid,
and I went not in the
top Israeli position
and not in a position to
qualify for the games.
The two races I needed to
pull Israel's best results--
Israel had only ever
achieved one fifth place
result in Placid.
I needed to achieve two
medal results for Israel.
Top six are medal in
skeleton, because it's
considered a very
difficult criteria to meet.
And so in the final two
races, I did pull two medals
and qualified-- we
found out January 16
that I had received the
invite for the Olympic Games.
SPEAKER: So now, you're
going to the Olympics.
You're one of 10 athletes
representing Israel.
What was the opening
ceremonies like, and then
what was the event like, I
mean, being on the biggest world
stage?
AJ EDELMAN: A lot
of people asked
what the Olympics
in general is like.
And I essentially say
that the Olympics is,
from an athlete's
perspective, at least to me,
it was like a big summer camp.
It's just a
televised summer camp
with lots of external
drama for the TV viewers.
But walking into
the stadium was--
you know that it's a
momentous occasion.
You know that,
forever, when people
look at opening ceremonies
for the 2018 games,
they're going to see the
Israeli delegation walk in,
and you are one of
those 10 athletes.
It's a huge-- it's not a
weight, but you feel it.
So walking into the stadium,
it was a Friday night.
And Friday night is Sabbath,
and as I wasn't using my phone.
And so, I'm probably
the only one
in that stadium
who wasn't videoing
walking into the stadium.
Everybody else is like, walking
in with a flag in one hand
and a phone in the other hand.
And so, they're walking
both flags in both hands.
But it was just
incredible experience
to walk into that same.
It's indescribable, the
feeling that you have,
knowing that you are
there for your country.
SPEAKER: And then, how did
the Olympics go for you?
AJ EDELMAN: That's a bit
more of a nuanced question.
The Olympics, I treat
it as any other race.
I was there to do a job.
All right.
So the Olympics seem like a
great big party, and in a way,
they are.
Like, they're a massively
expensive, huge big party.
But for me, as a
skeleton athlete,
I'm sent there by my country.
The only reason I'm
there is because I
was given an invite
by my country to go
do a job on their behalf.
And so I approached the race
like any other race that I had.
Spent all of my day
working on the track.
It was a new track, so I
didn't have any notes on it.
I didn't have a coach there
who could help me out.
And so it was just
trying everyday
to work on how I could become
better during my skeleton run.
It was a difficult
time, because it
seemed like there were all
these distractions that you
could take part in.
And to some extent,
I think that if I
were to ever go to
another Olympics,
that I'd make more
of the distractions.
Like, you should you should
partake in part of the party.
But the Olympics
were not extremely--
they didn't go as
expected, because it
was all work and no play.
SPEAKER: So I want to talk a
little bit about some themes
that you've kind
of mentioned today.
Perseverance seems to be
the definition of you,
being told so many
times that you're
the wrong fit, wrong sport.
How do you approach overcoming
some of the negativity that
was brought in and to become
one of the best in your sports?
AJ EDELMAN: I have two modes.
If I'm passionate
about something,
there's really a 0 and a 1.
I'm either off or on.
So when I'm on, it's full on.
If I'm being told that I
can't accomplish something,
then I'm going to go and
accomplish it whenever I can.
A lot of that is
additional self-motivation,
like that commercial from P&G.
But for the most part, I
made a promise to myself
to do things in a certain way,
to achieve certain things.
And I never actually--
it's really one promise that
I never wanted to break.
SPEAKER: With a sport that's
so seemingly individualized,
how do you look at the
teamwork and leadership
and different pieces to
such a kind of a solo sport?
AJ EDELMAN: It is a solo sport.
So as I mentioned, skeleton, the
athlete qualifies the country,
but he's not necessarily
the one to go.
And so skeleton is very
aggressive in terms
of people needing to
jump places to get
to where they need to get.
Because all of us
as Olympic athletes,
we eat, sleep, and
basically live,
we breathe, for this
single point four years
in the future or eight years
in the future, whatever
it might be.
The Olympics is everything.
And so you would do almost
anything to get there.
The decision to sacrifice
potential points for myself
in order to give Israel a
bigger chance of qualifying
was a really difficult one, but
it was the team aspect of it,
where if you have more people
on the different circuits,
you can try to
cover those bases.
So even though it
is a solo sport,
as somebody who was
leading our team,
it was my obligation
to put in a policy that
would help us as a team.
SPEAKER: What advice
would you give
to someone who's looking
to not just become
maybe the best athlete
in their field,
but the best in their field.
AJ EDELMAN: Everybody
is different,
so it's difficult to
dispense very general advice.
I'd say that if you set out to
actually accomplish something,
then there is--
I always talk to
kids, and I usually
describe it as, there's is
an opening to your book,
there's beginning to your book,
there's a table of contents,
and that table of contents
is not yet written.
And there's an end to your book.
And we know how the
story always ends.
The story will end either when
we pass on, or when we stop.
Right?
And so what happens in between?
So you get to write
all those pages
of what happens in between.
So for me, I knew that I
start as a skeleton athlete,
and I was going to finish when
I retired as a skeleton athlete.
Was there going to
be a chapter that
was called "Olympic
Games," or was there going
to be a chapter called
"The Decision to Quit."
And so for me, there
would never be a chapter
called "The Decision to Quit."
SPEAKER: So are you trying
to qualify for 2022?
AJ EDELMAN: I wish.
No, not actually.
After the Olympics,
I kind of took
stock of where I was in life.
I realized I was 27 years old.
And there was more
potential for fresh blood
to come in who did have the
components of being a far more
competitive skeleton athlete.
And so I shifted my focus to
recruiting a far better athlete
than myself to come
into the program.
So thankfully,
after the Olympics,
we got a lot of interest in
people joining the program.
So we have four new athletes
in the program itself,
and I coach them.
Because when I was
doing the sport,
I didn't actually have a coach
who traveled around with me.
It was one of the
biggest drawbacks
to being not part
of a big program
is I didn't get that
developmental leg up.
But for the new
athletes in our sport,
I get to act as that coach.
So I video them on
a constant basis.
I'm in touch with them
almost every single day.
And I'm their liaison to--
I mean, that has become
my new passion project.
SPEAKER: So there are
a lot of Olympians that
struggle post-athletic career.
You're now coaching.
What else are you working
on, and how have you
kind of approached
the post-Olympic life?
AJ EDELMAN: The post-Olympic
life is a difficult transition,
I think.
The effect of coming down
from training every day
and living a mission that
completely defines your life
is just too difficult
to describe.
It becomes a really big mental
health problem to tackle.
So I mean, we call it
the Olympic come down.
So after the Olympics,
you're all hyped up.
You've just represented your
country, and now it's all gone.
Like, to me, as I
described it, it
felt like if somebody
was a surgeon,
and somebody had removed their
ability to perform surgery.
And so I lost my reason
almost for operating.
So it's just
difficult to overcome.
And it's a continual effort to
find passions to replace that,
to find opportunity
to replace it.
So mentoring the
new Israeli athletes
and making sure that we have
a continuing Olympic team,
that's something that
I've been working on.
Another thing is I'm looking
for a new opportunity in life
back in tech, or otherwise.
So that's where I am right
now, building the Israeli team,
and finding my next opportunity.
SPEAKER: As a coach?
Do you ever get the urge
to go down yourself?
AJ EDELMAN: Yes.
Yeah.
SPEAKER: Every single time?
AJ EDELMAN: Yeah.
In fact, I told my
parents couple weeks,
I was like, OK, that's it.
I'm going back to the sport.
I'm going to do bobsled.
But you realize
that's just like the--
that's just the loneliness
of not having sport again.
That's that talking that.
You have to make
smart decisions,
and the smart decision is to be
supportive of the new athletes
rather than just
taking a joy ride again
for the next four years.
SPEAKER: And what's the outlook
for the Israeli bobsled team
in 2022?
AJ EDELMAN: Oh, we have
these four new athletes.
The athlete who competed
alongside me last year,
he's still doing the program,
he's still doing the sport,
and he is Israel's hope
for the 2022 games.
The new athletes are
hope for the 2026 games.
And they're looking incredibly
promising, actually.
In fact, one is an incredible
100 meter sprinter.
And so we have very
high hopes for him.
I'm also trying to put
together a female bobsled team
and a female mono
bobsled team, which
is a very brand new sport.
Mono bobsled is just a single
person that sits in the sled.
If mono bobsled had been around
when I was starting this sport,
I definitely would
have done mono bob.
But the female
version is now out,
and so I'm recruiting for that.
SPEAKER: Awesome.
So I do want to open it
up to audience questions.
We're going to have a
microphone up there, if anybody
wants to ask one.
While people line up, I have one
kind of fun question for you.
The Olympic Village is pretty
notorious and pretty famous.
What's the best
family friendly story
you can share from your
time in the Olympic Village?
AJ EDELMAN: The
family friendly story.
So the Olympic Village
is our new homes.
It's kind of like
living in a dorm room,
and a pretty packed
dorm room at that.
Athletes share each
room with each other.
There's sometimes three
athletes to a room, sometimes.
Very rarely does an
athlete get a single room.
So we're all in close
quarters, sometimes
with our heads of teams.
And so if you're working
on your equipment,
you're working on your equipment
basically on your dinner table,
or where you might eat.
And so for me, there
was actually a story
that revolved around my helmet.
And my helmet contained
an image of Samson.
And Samson is a religious
figure, so to speak.
And so I was told by
the Olympic Committee
after I started
training with his helmet
that I'd have to cover him up.
It's against the Olympic Charter
to have religious propaganda
on your person.
So I ran around
Pyeongchang, which
is kind of like
nowheresville, looking
for a can of spray paint.
And I couldn't find the
spray paint anywhere,
and so I traveled
to Gangneung, which
is miles away where the
figure skaters were living.
I finally found a can of
spray paint, but I then
turned our closet into--
I turned our closet
in our dorm room
into this very noxious like,
spray painting studio, where
I was taking my helmet, and I
had a makeshift bandanna on,
and I taped over, and
I was spray painting
over this whole helmet.
I never spray painted before.
But it's something that
all these athletes do,
where they have to
modify their equipment,
but they're doing it basically
like, on their tables.
SPEAKER: Wow.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks for coming.
So from my experience, I
played like, very high-caliber
competitive tennis growing up.
And so I really related
to your statement
about it being very individual.
So I guess my question
is, how did you
reconcile the whole like,
it's individual and very solo,
but at the same time,
you're playing in a team,
but you're still trying to
take each other's places,
in that sense?
And how did you reconcile
that fact and deal
with that pressure?
AJ EDELMAN: It's really hard.
It's incredibly
difficult, because when
you compete you're actually
also competing-- as you know,
you're competing with
them in the same races.
So your success comes at
their expense, and vice versa.
How I personally reconciled it
was that when I started out,
I started out for a mission.
And that mission was to
try to accomplish something
where Israel would get
to the Olympic Games.
I had to keep that
mission in perspective
that Israel would get
the Olympic Games one
way or another.
But at the same time, I
believed personally, internally,
that I was the only
person who could do that.
When I thought I was going to
quit in 2016, one of the things
that I had said to myself
when I decided to unquit like,
five minutes later, was that I'm
the only person who can proudly
represent us in
the way that I want
us represented in the Olympics.
Like, I have to be the one.
And so I'm going to
support the rest of my team
in trying to get there,
but at the same time,
I need to be that
standard bearer.
And so it's difficult
to reconcile.
I competed in multiple
races with the person who
was directly challenging me.
And so that led to a lot of--
it leads to difficult friction.
But at the same time, if
you believe internally
that you are the
best suited to do it,
then it actually removes the
component of a them versus you,
and makes it a you
versus the field.
So they just become
part of that field.
And so if I thought that I
myself was the best, the best
Israeli, then I was really
just trying to qualify myself
rather than to beat him.
AUDIENCE: AJ, thanks
for coming in.
The main thing I'm wondering
about is the perseverance.
You mentioned that one time,
that you were especially
considering dropping out,
but then you got reinspired.
And so I was just
wondering if kind of there
were other times where
maybe very frequently,
you were oscillating about it.
It just seems very
impressive to me
to maintain a very continued
intensity and belief
that you can push through.
AJ EDELMAN: I wanted
to quit multiple times.
That was a time that I
actually decided to quit.
So the frequency with which
I suffered minor burnouts
was quite high, because
the volume that I was doing
and the workload
that I had sustained.
I think the Olympics
are a measure, not just
of this athletic
success, because there's
an immense amount of gifted
athletic individuals all
over the world.
And Lord knows, I'm far
from the most gifted
athletic individual.
But most of qualifying for
the Olympics, I believe,
is that it's like
this unbroken belief
that you can accomplish it.
And so, every time
that I wanted to quit--
it was really quite often.
It was a few times
per season, usually
if there was like a bad injury,
or a bad result. Then it
simply--
it required, as I
mentioned before,
the belief that I was the
only one who could do this.
And so if I was the only
one who could do it,
then I was removing the
ability of Israel to qualify.
I was actually taking
that away from them.
I'd promised them
that I would give them
that ability four years
before, two years before.
But if I pulled out, it
would be like stealing.
And so, I stealing my potential,
I was stealing their potential.
And that's pretty much
how I kept from straying
too far into the quit mindset.
SPEAKER: Any other questions?
I have one more I want to ask.
If you were going to be
in the summer Olympics,
what sport would you
want to participate in?
AJ EDELMAN: Weightlifting.
SPEAKER: Weightlifting.
AJ EDELMAN: Yeah.
I love weightlifting.
Lifting big things
is like, so much fun.
Part of our training is--
so our training is
actually-- it consists
during the summer--
a lot of people
ask how we train
during the summer.
During the summer,
there's no ice anywhere.
And you can only train in
skeleton on a skeleton on ice
at a bobsled track.
And bobsled tracks
are only built
in places that have hosted
the Olympics before,
because nobody wants to
build this $300 million
waste of wasted concrete.
And so during the summer, all
we do is we lift and we sprint.
And so we do these Olympic
lifts, these cleans
and snatches, and that develops
explosive hip movements,
and we sprint.
And so I spent an
immense amount of time
in the gym just doing
this weightlifting.
And at first, I was
actually really bad at it.
I didn't know how to clean.
So it looked like, you know,
every time the bar would
go over the head, I actually
wouldn't be able to hold it.
And so it'd fall back,
and I'd fall back.
And it looked quite pathetic.
But over time, over
a lot of repetition,
it became quite second nature.
And so I thought
like, if I was going
to do another Olympic
sport, it would probably
be weightlifting.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so
much for the stories.
Really inspiring.
I'm originally from Jamaica, so
thanks for the "Cool Runnings."
AJ EDELMAN: I actually
trained in Jamaica.
AUDIENCE: All right.
We have to talk about that.
But two things are
really impressive.
Your ability to
set really stretch
goals, like I'm
struggling in school,
so I'm going to get into MIT.
Or I'm overweight.
I'm going to become an Olympian.
Like, how do you do that?
Those are really,
really strong goals.
And the other question is I know
the ad, and it's very powerful.
And if you could speak a
little bit about the role
your parents played
in your experience?
AJ EDELMAN: Yeah, of course.
My parents are
actually here today.
[APPLAUSE]
So a couple of--
so I'll speak in order
of how you asked it.
But I'll actually touch on the
"Cool Runnings" thing first.
Every year was a
challenge to figure out
where I was going to
spend my time training.
And there was multiple options.
I could train in
Israel, which had
the advantage of being close
to my homeland, and very close
to the mission at hand.
But in the final summer, when
it looked like it would be
an incredibly difficult push--
I didn't know whether I was
going to make the Games at all
during that summer.
In fact, it looked
pretty doubtful.
And so I thought,
much in line with what
you mentioned of
stretching goals,
I thought what is the craziest--
who are the craziest best
sprinters in the world?
Now, the craziest best sprinters
in the world are Jamaicans.
So certainly if I go
to Jamaica and learn
from a Jamaican coach, they
have some tips and tricks
to teach somebody
who has absolutely
no skill at sprinting how
to be a good sprinter.
Right?
So I hooked up with my
Jamaican bobsled friends.
And I said, do you
guys have a good coach?
Like, do you have
a coach somewhere?
And they said, (JAMAICAN
ACCENT) yeah, man.
Sorry.
[LAUGHTER]
Yes, man.
We can hook you up with this guy
in Spanish Town, right outside
of Kingston.
And you'll stay with him.
He's a great coach.
And so I did.
I went down there, I trained.
And it was actually an
incredibly difficult summer
for me, because on top of
the heat, a lot of times,
we lacked running water.
And Spanish Town is not
the safest place for me.
But it was an
incredible experience.
Speaking to why going to the
extremes, I feel that if--
in engineering, you
guys are all engineers,
so you know boundary conditions.
Right?
So for me, it was about testing
ranges and boundary conditions.
I wanted to always
go to the extreme.
If I wanted to do
something, I wanted to do it
to the utmost, best ability.
And so there was no point
doing anything other than that.
I don't think anybody starts
out and says, you know what?
I want to be the 35,000th ranked
chess player in the world.
They want to be the best, right?
In the meantime, they'll
settle in at a certain rank,
but they want to be the best.
So for me, if I wasn't doing--
if I didn't have
any academic goals,
what was the number
one academic goal?
Get into MIT.
If I wanted to be
accomplished in sport,
the number one
way to do that was
by going to the Olympic Games.
In terms of my parents,
who supported me,
they supported me
in multiple ways.
The first is emotional.
They were incredibly
supportive of the journey.
I think it's very
difficult for parents
who know their child
has the potential
to accomplish
something in a more
established industry,
and something
a little more certain.
Certainly, they didn't know
when I started my time at MIT
that, after
graduating from MIT, I
would actually just drop
everything and go and do
sports.
And so I think it came as
a bit of a shock to them,
but they were incredibly
supportive of it.
And so that I appreciate
their support every day.
It was incredible.
Number two was, when I cut
the supply line to Oracle--
this was one of the extremes
that I did when I left Oracle.
When I decide to stay in
the sport and to make 2018,
the number one way of
doing that, I thought,
was cutting off all lifelines
to my previous life.
Whereas during that
season, I always
thought, well, if
this doesn't work out,
I can go back to a really nice
salary and a very comfortable
living in California.
Like, it's available to me.
The job's there.
Supposed to go back
there that summer.
When I decided to
not quit, I thought
that the number one
way to stay on track
was not by completely
burning the bridge,
but removing that potential.
I could no longer
go back to that job.
And so that involved
removing a source of income.
And so skeleton
is very expensive.
And thankfully, my
parents helped support me
on the rest of my journey.
And without them, I wouldn't
have been able to afford it.
But I'm incredibly
thankful to them.
They played a huge part.
AUDIENCE: Thanks for
sharing your experience.
Could you talk about the role of
religion in your Olympic story,
and how did that play on
a day to day business?
AJ EDELMAN: Sure.
Religion defined who
I was as an athlete,
because I was competing
on behalf of a community.
So one of the things that I
learned early on from somebody
who is a sports psychologist
was that you need to center
yourself before a competition.
So you need to always go
back to a specific markers,
so that you know where you are.
And so that to me was a
saying, it was a mantra.
And so the mantra I came up with
was for myself, for my people,
and for my country.
So I was representing
the country of Israel,
but I was representing
the people of Israel,
the Jewish people, as well as--
there are non-Jewish Israelis.
I was representing them.
But I wore a kippah.
Everywhere I went,
I wore a kippah.
When the directive
came-- a few years ago,
the directive came from the
Israeli security personnel--
that the guidelines
for Israeli athletes--
because it was quite
dangerous for Israeli athletes
to travel, especially in Europe
while wearing Israeli gear,
that we were not to travel
outside of competition venue
with markings of
an Israeli athlete,
including potentially kippot.
So this a kippah.
And so, instead of
actually removing that,
I went to the extreme and
ordered a full kit of gear,
of a shirt that said Israeli
Bobsled and Skeleton Team,
pants which said Israeli
and jackets which said Israeli
Bobsled and Skeleton Team.
That way, every time I was
walking around on a plane,
it would start a conversation.
Oh, Israel has a bobsled
and skeleton team?
So that, to me, it was a
central part of my identity.
And it helped
motivate me further.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
SPEAKER: Well, AJ, thank
you for being here.
Let's give him a
round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]